i will move to the next session
which is going to be uh
a discussion
on uh some of the work that i do as a
mentor in uh
in another program that uh
has some collaboration with find biotech
uh am i going to
i need to share my slides right now
right
yes so just briefly again thank you for
all the panelists and this is actually
going to be a um
the final
part of today and so i do want to
mention that tomorrow we will have a
chance to hear from
some of the next steps and more
practical ways of how
many of the students that we are
interacting with can get involved in
meaningful projects using bioinformatics
tools communicating with mentors uh
finding out interesting projects and and
this transition part of today's session
is going to kind of uh build the
expectation on how we move from just
learning about these exciting fields to
practically you know what a student or
somebody who's beginning to be involved
in this
domain
uh could actually
do practically so
uh thank you geo uh we'll have just
briefly i'll just uh kind of mention
what's the plan we will have uh
uh dr duponyano chavez speak about the
sip program and uh the mentorship and
we'll have uh miss urja park uh speak
about her experience
uh being mentored and participating in
astrobiology as well as other types of
research and mr suprajet
will speak about his
astrobiology endeavors and what he is up
to next
and then finally i will conclude with
some
perspective on the omics logic research
fellowship on how you can get involved
in some of the topics that we discussed
today as a contributor as a mentor
and as someone that can help us build
out a pathway for students to get
involved in a meaningful way so please
go ahead geo thank you
thank you julia
do you see my screen
yes
okay perfect
all right so
um
because of the work that the science
internship program has developed
over the years and at the university of
california i want to talk about this
issue with inequalities
and i generally use it to think about
inequalities in the context of the on my
own country brazil i come from brazil so
i uh in front of you
is a picture that i i grew up watching
so in the right we see a few people with
a lot and in the left we see a lot with
very little
uh this is in brazil this is due to
historical
for historic historical reasons
and so i think that education
represents really a way that we have to
uh
counterbalance inequalities that we have
in the countries
i was kind of surprised when i realized
that there are inequalities in the
united states as well because we all
hear of the united states as the number
one economy and things like that
but there are there have to be politics
to address inequality issues in the
united in developed countries as well as
in developing countries
so
uh
i have this question of what are the
boundaries between science and education
because when i was growing up i really
did not
see a clear
boundary or a clear limit between uh
science and education so in my mind up
to a point
i did not think that there was a
difference between what is science and
what is education so i guess for the
sake of simplicity here i am just
assuming that science and education are
the same thing maybe you do not agree
with me that's okay uh but just for the
sake of simplicity and the context that
i come from
because
in my country
in many situations in many occasions you
can pursue
an educational career
but uh but reaching into a faculty
position or reaching to a
position in academia can be something
really really challenging and as as as
you may imagine
uh there have there can be uh
many mechanisms of privilege in a
situation like brazil so what i want to
say here is that uh this program science
without borders
is the is a program that was launched by
the government of brazil about 10 years
ago and the political
uh social and economic situation uh at
that moment was completely different
from what it is nowadays from what it is
today in brazil i'm talking specifically
about brazil
uh but what happens is that there is a
need for the countries to invest in
sciences and in genomic sciences
specifically so what happens last what
happened
last year was that the government of
brazil has launched this uh program
called uh programma genomes brazil
and what the goal of this program is
is to sequence uh 1 000 brazilian
nationals uh
brazil has this particular particular
feature of being
the result
of the
uh mixing of three different three main
different populations europeans africans
and uh native americans so there is an
interest in understanding how that has
how that has an impact in understanding
disease uh in the country so what uh the
interest is right now in the country
is uh
to to stimulate
the sequencing of brazilian nationals
but this brings a problem
because
sequencing technologies are really
really expensive
and
brazil is not a rich country it's not a
developed country
so sequencing 1000 brazilians represents
a problem because there is a chance that
we are not going to represent the entire
population
we are not going to
uh
we're not going to have uh
kids or uh scientists from a
disadvantage economically disadvantaged
background involved in this process
so uh in my mind the problem uh that we
have right now in the country is that we
need to make science we need to make
education uh
reach
many of these different uh layers of
society i totally totally agree with dr
andino when he says that we need to make
science available for uh
all of the population both young
scientists and scientists there are more
seniors
but
i really think that
what we need to do in in brazil for
instance
is a
mindset in the education educational
culture we need to
more and more make science projects
available for students in in brazil and
these
uh this is with the hope that it will
will end up helping the public health
system to make education educated uh
decisions
based on the genetic background of the
population of brazil specifically so
this uh in my opinion this overlaps very
well with the mission of the university
of california santa cruz because in 2001
the human genome sequence was published
in part due to the efforts of ucsc
researchers here i'm basically talking
about uh dr david hoster who
who is considered to be to have played a
very important role in uh
in
in sequencing in the human genome
but also the the other program that i
have also been involved with is the
science internship program
this is i have been served as a mentor
in this program for six more than six
years at this point
and it aims to
foster the involvement of high school
students in science uh
this program was funded
funded in 2009 by dr raja gahatakurta
who is also a professor at ucsc both
both of these initiatives the genomic
research and sip grow every year
in fact we are just having a
conversation with the genomics institute
to design a bioinformatics course for uh
for for students of underrepresented
backgrounds
and uh as part of the effort that i have
uh
trying to do that i have been trying to
do to
to share the education that i have had
access with my uh
my national peers in brazil i was able
to help in hiring phd students and
professors from from that from brazil to
serve as mentors for american students
at the science internship program and
this is uh totally in alignment with the
mission of the sip program
as i will begin to explain to you right
now
uh
i consider myself very close to the
mission of sip and particularly to the
uh
the ideas that are on the founding
on the thoughts of the founding director
dr uh raja
and so sib has this initiative of
stimulating
critical thinking and research and the
goal is to create equity in uh
in what here we are calling steam for
science technology engineering arts and
mathematics
and so
that that part creating equity ins in
steam us
is the crest part so this is a
philosophy i would say
that was very present at the very start
of the program in 2009
right now the program has as i said it
grows every year
it has uh grown uh my understanding from
this part the starry starry night
program is uh is a program where
a person that works with
astrophysics
raja is a
a professor in the astrophysics
department at
ucsc
what happens here is that researchers
that were
observing the cosmos
they
receive students not necessarily here
high school students but students
younger younger than high school
students and what what they do is the is
that the students talk to the mentor
for one hour about the research that
they are doing
and so what happens here is that the
student has an opportunity to stay with
a mentor and see how
research is conducted and what the
mentor has to do is that he just needs
to adapt himself to the idea that he's
been followed by a student and he can
just do
his uh his research experiment and uh
and at the same time talk to the
talk to the to the students so this
exposes students to the idea to the
concept of science to the concept of
getting involved in a science project
and uh it is uh
this is a concept that uh raja brings to
the mentors all the time that a science
project is very important
for a student to work with
uh this has led to further developments
in the sip program
so uh
with these
python and research tutorials
called pyr
what
what raja does is he teaches
students
in basically an introduction to python
and they also
look into a research paper
sorry they look into a research paper
and the questions that are
being addressed in the research paper
are presented to the students in these
tutorial sessions
then
i joined sip i believe it was 2015.
pair i i actually don't not know when
prior started but just this year we
started teaching this other set set of
tutorials
we are calling them
recon bio for research in computational
biology and the idea here is to
basically
also
teach students
us
coding
i use r and bash
the terminal the command line
and here the idea is also present a
research research project and then
do some coding that answer the questions
that are present in the research in the
in the research article uh particular
particularly here we are in
during my phd i was really interested in
variants uh
invariants uh in the genome in the human
genome but because uh the star cov two
pandemic hit last year we switched to
studying uh mutations or variants in the
genome of sar
cov2 because it is uh it is really
many times challenging to work in a
computer a computer server with a human
genomic sequence
so because the genome of the virus
is smaller than the
human genome i decided to switch to
the virus it it it it's easier to work
with viral viral sequences than than
human sequences
so uh
i told i told you initiatives i
presented to you initiatives
that uh try to stimulate a scientific uh
character in students
and i um
i
i told you that uh we try we right now
we're developing the idea of doing this
even before
high school but uh sip really works with
high school students
and really uh when the student comes to
an internship with a mentor during the
summer with sib
uh what we do
is we have the students follow us
in the lab
doing
an experiment and also
doing some
coding experiments as i mentioned just
last year we changed a little bit to
studying the sarcov genome rather than
the human genome but really here the
idea is to
reinforce the need to expose students to
the concept of a scientific project
so that
they decide
or they have the experience to
develop a scientific project and they
can pursue a career in science maybe in
a university or maybe in another
institution that allows them to develop
further their scientific career
so after this all ends there are
initiatives that that c work with for
instance the global sphere network
uh sphere stands for stem programs for
high schoolers engaging in research
early
and it is a combination of uh
programs that intend to uh
mentor high school students and also
along the years other initiatives have
joined forces
with these
with step so sorry
what we have right now is the alumni
bodies which is
basically uh more senior
high school students that have
been
mentored
years uh before the current students
they provide some advice on the research
presentation
on the uh
the
many times
uh these students are using the dorms
and the buildings at the university uh
so things like uh information about
places to eat or uh how to go for the uh
for the
extracurricular activities that are
provided by seed
are these are these this information
that is provided by alumni the alumni
bodies uh
initiative
uh
this sip is for teachers in sib and the
idea here is expanding
expanding uh the sip initiative to
sips i believe it's it's teachers in in
the county
c-sip is community college
sip the idea here is to provide
community college students with some
exposure to
uh to a scientific project working with
mentor or working
with uh
with a professional in academia
so in conclusion
i think i need to finish here
uh i think that education and science
have the potential to help in correcting
historical social inequalities
in the in both developed and developing
countries
this maintains an ecosystem that is
necessary for the
social structure in both these types of
of countries
and the goal here i believe is to
provide access to education and into
medicine to
all individuals in
in these societies
particularly i believe in developing
countries the governments need to have
initiatives to invest in the formation
of human resources
uh
to correct for these historical
inequalities and also to maintain a
minimum access to education in medicine
and i believe this is where
i fit because uh i don't know if i told
you but my studies were funded by the
government of brazil and so
i need to work to
allow
education to be available for
for the brazilian society
so i would like to end here and thank
you so much for
this opportunity
oh i i finna i just finished my slides
uh
we see that pine biotech also works to
connect students to academia and to
professionals uh to the academia
professionals that are designing the
curriculum and the opportunities that
shape the future of bioinformatics
research
so so brigitte uh thank you draculiano
for uh your presentation
thank you and uh i do want to mention
that uh
jio is also starting to mentor a couple
of students
in one of our programs which i'll talk
about in just a few more minutes but now
we want to hear from
subrajit barua and kind of hear about
the way he got interested and got
actively involved in bioinformatics and
astrobiology thank you so much and
i'll share my screen
real quick
all right so first of all i would like
to thank the organizing committee of
biotech for providing this opportunity
and
as the theme for today
was the changing role of bioinformatics
i would like to talk about how
bioinformatics is being used all over
the globe to leverage astrobiological
studies and the researchers of
astrobiology all across the globe so
before we move on to
the research of going on the projects
and what i'm doing first of all a brief
introduction of who am i and what am i
currently doing so i began
my bioinformatics journey from find
biotech itself so i am an ex research
intern it is here where i got to learn
about the various algorithms got to
learn about transcriptomics genomics
multiomics data science machine learning
and this is really the place where i was
baptized with bioinformatics data
science and its biological applications
after that i moved on for my higher
education and currently i'm a master's
student pursuing molecular biology and
biotechnology from itma university saint
petersburg russia and i am also 100
government government-funded scholar
here from the russian government which
is a big opportunity given to me for
studying higher getting higher education
and also doing a lot of research
talking about research and i am here
enrolled in the scammed international
laboratories at
university and i'm a member of the
applied genomics lab and my supervisor
is dr alexey komisarov and under him i
am working on a couple of projects
include involving human transcriptomics
epigenetics and also certain
astrobiological experiments and research
projects about which i'll be talking in
just a while
apart from that
since i love astrobiology so much i am a
part of an initiative
uh startup in india which is called
space nova and i'm currently the head at
the department of astrobiology at
spaceunova we have a
vision and a mission to make india one
of those space faring
ecosystem in the world where each and
every individual has the capability and
the resources to become a space
technologist
and
since i love to communicate and spread
the word of astrobiology everywhere i'm
also an art and scientific communicator
at art of inquiry and i'm working on
indirect julia broadsky she is a ceo of
art of inquiry and also a forward nasa
astronaut trainer and here you can see
some of the examples where i have been
doing this science communication stuff
basically in the domain of astrobiology
so that's like a lot of
information about me but let's focus on
what i'm going to talk about today that
is astrobiology
so
if
i'm asked to define the term
astrobiology and what is it actually
well a very crisp and short answer would
be it's a very multi-disciplinary domain
of science which involves a lot of you
can say sub domains or parts of science
for example origin of life on earth
itself it's still a mystery and it's
being explored how did life originate on
earth similarly we also have this very
curious question which we try to find
the answer of that is life
there outside anywhere or of earth is
life there in any of the other planets
or satellites or any of those discovered
exoplanets because just like in today's
talk dr the surma pointed out that there
are so many other earth-like planets all
across the universe so who knows maybe
in one of those planets life do exist
and to understand that and to find out
if life does exist somewhere else it is
very essential to study the geology and
environmental conditions of those
planets so that can be considered as one
of the domains of astrobiology and
finally the domain in which i am most
interested and excited about is space
health there's a lot of risks involved
with space travel and
with more and more focus being given on
long-term missions like a mission
to moon or even to mars
is going to take a lot of time and
exposure to certain factors for such a
long time
will have an effect on the human health
and the human body so i'm really
interested to investigate and to prepare
ourselves before we embark on such a
mission so that this kind of mission
will have the least impact and the most
outcome in a positive manner
so talking about origin of life well
there has been a lot of talk going on in
the recent days that life might be there
on mars or maybe if not more some of the
moons of some of the icy giants like
europa or titan but till today
with
all the scientific advancements that we
have had over the past many years our
dear planet earth is the only place
where we know that life exists and
exists in harmony grows and prospers
everywhere so
talking about the life on earth
extremophiles just like dr adasara
pointed out are those categories of
microbial organism which really poses a
question to us how much do we do we
really understand life
what is the extent of life and what is
the range in which life can survive well
for a lot of time i used to believe that
life is confined in a very short range
but how wrong was i because talking
about the extreme condition of volcanic
eruptions very high temperature
poisonous gases lava coming out
life should not exist but we do have
species of bacteria like streptomyces
thermophilic which do survive in such
high conditions high temperature
conditions
talking about a highly acidic or
alkaline leak
life should not
perform very well at such an absurd ph
condition but again we talked about
certain extremophiles for example
acetate thio bacillus thioxidanes which
can survive and dr dasar also gave
wonderful examples of so many
extremophiles with so many unique
characteristics and properties and
finally
this gave me a real shock that
for many years i used to believe that
life can never survive in space
out of house atmosphere in the vacuum
with so much of radiation and
fluctuating temperature going on life
should never have a chance that's the
reason why we wear space source but this
microorganism dynafucker's radioduran
survived for almost a year exposed
completely to the harsh environmental
conditions of space aboard the
international space station this was a
part of the tan proper mission was by
jaxa and this really opened up a new
horizon and a new boundary of
exploration and that's how i have been
so much excited about astrobiology
because this really
begs us to ask the question how much do
we really understand life what is the
extent of life
as i was saying earlier i am really
interested about space health about
taking care of the health of astronauts
to understand what happens when somebody
goes on a space mission
there are various factors which play a
role and one of the most exciting factor
is microgravity because once we go out
of earth's gravity very strange things
begin to happen
these are some pictures which we are all
familiar with we have seen these sort of
pictures all across the internet but if
you notice some strange phenomenon
happens once the acceleration due to
gravity which we are all habituated to
that is 9.8 meter per second square
ceases to exist for example a droplet of
water does not fall down because there's
no gravity anymore
but takes this sort of a circular
droplet shape because of the now
dominating surface tension force
similarly there are a lot of fluids in
our body for example our blood or
cerebrospinal fluid so this is a
question which i always ponder about
what happens to those fluids in our body
there's also fluids inside our cells
which play a role in signaling and stuff
so there's a lot of hormones and enzymes
what happens those chemicals once
a person travels to space
and
lives in the condition of microgravity
so even though space travel seems very
very exciting for all of us there's a
lot of challenges which these astronauts
have to face for example altered gravity
there's both microgravity as well as
hypergravity
then there's a high dose of ionizing
radiation there's low pressure and low
oxygen which can act as stress factors
the
unusual condition of isolation does have
an effect on the psychology and the
physical nature of the astronauts and
definitely there's uh really altered
atmospheric gas concentration in space
so there has been a very
good amount of questions going on today
as well during the symposium that
there's a lot of things going on in the
space biology domain but is
the data available for us to analyze and
what how can we actually use
bioinformatics to leverage those sort of
studies
so here is the answer to that because
nasa and other space agencies have been
looking at space comics for a long long
time but it is only recently that the
growing interest of astrobiological
research among other researchers as well
as students have really forced people to
form consortiums and groups such as the
gene labs and international standard for
space comics who
really
take care of this sort of data and
curate them and make them publicly
available for research this typical idea
was really fostered by the twin study a
unique opportunity for mankind to study
what happens to humans once they are
sent to space so they were the kenny
brothers and they are identical twins
one of them served as a ground control
on earth and the other twin went to
space and spent
uh some days less than a year about the
international space station and once he
returned their
dna was taken sequenced and the various
omics domain were investigated there was
genomic study transfer comic study study
of the telomere and also multi-omics
study
and those sort of studies really gave us
the idea
that there's definitely certain changes
that can be noticed in the person who
traveled to space some of them resolved
after a span of six months or so whereas
some of them were really permanent and
they were mostly epigenetic studies
changes in the length of telomeres and
stuff
so
with
these sort of have
really crazy projects happening all
across the globe me as an enthusiast of
astrobiologists really got interested in
space omics and currently i'm really in
the beginning of looking into this
particular domain and i am investigating
the gene expression of various model
organisms plant model organisms like
adiabatopsis and as well as human cell
lines with the help of publicly
available data and i'm utilizing
bioinformatics and machine learning
algorithms like pca and hierarchical
clustering to generate meaningful data
to study the differentially expressed
genes
to study the pathways which are altered
and
with that i would like to say that that
is like the outline of
my projects that i'm currently working
on i'm depending upon the publicly
available data
in the various
consortiums and various repositories and
really comparing them with space flight
as being one of the conditions versus
the ground control and its effect in
isolated factors like isolated
microgravity or isolated ionizing
radiation there's different organisms
that i'm studying for example model
organisms like zebra fish
and
mice and drosophila arabidopsis and also
certain human cell lines and there's a
need for this field to grow there's a
lot of opportunity and with the correct
mentorship and correct guidance i
believe more and more students all
across the globe can really learn about
astrobiology and contribute big time to
this growing field of science and me as
an enthusiast would definitely love to
contribute and do some more research and
to
understand what actually happens and how
we can address some of the problems that
originate when long-term space flight is
taken so thank you so much for having me
here and
if you have any questions or if you have
any suggestions any feedbacks definitely
feel free to reach out to me
thank you very much and uh great to see
both the presentation that you prepared
and great to interact with you about
your project
um i wonder if you could introduce uh
orja i'll just briefly say from my side
uh that you know urja represents one of
those people that
has
a lot of determination as far as i can
tell to get to where she needs to go
and as a result was able to apply
herself in many different areas
only some of them include bioinformatics
from which i know
but i'm looking forward to hearing about
your talk please go ahead
yeah so to introduce you urja well she
is
a visiting scholar at blue marble space
institute of science and also a research
intern at pine biotech she is really
passionate about astrobiology as well
just like myself and she is doing some
really cool projects and trying to
explore more so
i think it's better to hear from urja
herself so i won't spoil anything it's
over to you
thank you so much ilya and thank you so
much for that uh lovely introduction
i would like to begin with sharing my
screen
all right so um so rajit has given a
really nice presentation on astrobiology
and how we can apply omics to
astrobiology
and as part of
my project with blue marble space
institute of science
i am working on dinofocus radiodurans
which is an extremophile which uh sir
rajeev also mentioned
and i'm working with dr dimitra atri and
i have collaborated with pine biotech to
do my project
but before i start talking about it i
would like to first introduce myself
uh so i recently graduated in biomedical
science
from nashville institute of management
studies in mumbai
and i will now be beginning my phd at
the german cancer research center which
is in heidelberg germany
i'm also as already mentioned a visiting
research scholar with blue marble space
and i am working on astrobiology
projects over there
so um i started my studies in biomedical
sciences in 2016 where i gained a lot of
knowledge in many different areas of
biology
in 2018 i worked at a lab
in mumbai where i was
involved in several different projects
where i also discovered new strains of
yeast and uv neutrogenized them to make
them sensitive to a particular
antibiotic and i was also involved in
creating a shuttle vector uh which was
uh
expressing a type of gene from yeast
that made it a red in color
um i then worked in the field of
nanotechnology where i synthesized zinc
oxide nanoparticles from a plant extract
the plant was dinosaur portfolio
in 2020 i collaborated with pine biotech
as a research fellow and with that i had
my first omics project ever and
i think that project usually boosted my
color
where i tried and elicited certain
biomarkers that are highly expressed in
glioblastoma stem cells
next for my master's thesis i work
worked at a hospital and i'm also
currently working there where i am
involved in several studies uh one
wherein i am trying to establish certain
biomarkers for diseases like
intracellular hematoma and traumatic
brain injury and i have also used
machine learning to create a diagnostic
system uh that can uh
it can diagnose the rise in serum
creatinine in patients
um and now i will be starting my journey
in a set where i'll be posting my phd in
cancer biology
so uh just to give you an overview of
the first omics project that i pursued
with pine biotech uh glioblastoma
multiform is a very aggressive type of
brain cancer and a patient has a
survival period of only 15 months post
therapy what i intended to do was to try
and identify the origin of this
particular type of cancer and according
to a current hypothesis this particular
type of cancer can originate from either
cancer stem cells or it can originate
from normal neurostem cells that have
undergone some sort of transformation
into a cancerous phenotype so in order
to solve this question i performed rna
sequence analysis uh so i took a data
set from the geodatabase where i took 40
samples 20 of normal neural stem cells
and 20 of glioma stem cells and
performed rna sleep analysis
what i observed was these two types of
stem cells were
genetically different
and
that
no there was a particular outside sample
that had certain similarities between
normal stem cells and glioma stem cells
which i believe could be an important uh
hint as um it would give an important
clue regarding how normally your stem
cells are transformed to glioma stem
cells
i was able to obtain 192 genes that were
significantly upregulated and 156 that
were significantly downregulated in
glioma stem themselves
from there i was also able to identify
several important pathways that may be
driving tumor genesis and glioblastomas
like the wing signaling pathway tgf beta
particle in the wedge of signaling
pathway and apart from that i was also
able to identify several genes that have
currently known on association with this
particular type of cancer
so i was able to use omix data analysis
to identify several types of biomarkers
that can be potentially exploited uh in
the future as therapeutic targets
now coming to my work with astrobiology
with blue marble space as i mentioned i
am working with dinofocus radiodurants
which is an extremophile that i'll be
talking about soon
the reason why i have chosen uh to
pursue this particular project and to
work with blue marble space is because
astrobiology happens to be one of those
areas which really interests me and
maybe in the future i would like to even
pursue a career in this field and
because um
the research that is happening in this
particular field is not necessarily only
related uh to space biology but with
this kind of research we can actually
help people on earth as well and i'll be
talking about how
that is possible so the title of my
project is multi-omics analysis of
dinofocus radiodurans uh and how we can
uh exploit its radio resistant
properties for space travel and even
cancer therapy
so um
space is not complete vacuum uh i mean
it is but there are certain other things
that may be influencing the health of an
astronaut in space
so um there are different types of
radiations that uh pose a very massive
threat to the health of astronauts when
they are in space and as we uh progress
with advances in technologies that may
bring us closer to traveling to mars uh
the threats also
remain
so we need to evade those sort of um
environmental stresses that we may find
in space and those are stresses like
solar radiation galactic radiation and
even
radiation that may be trapped inside the
magnetosphere
now the reason why we are trying to
evade this particular risk is because
ionizing radiation can cause very very
um
drastic changes in the human body
uh it can lead to cancer it can cause
loss of vision it can cause um skin
burns it can cause several health
problems in astronauts and if we are
talking about long-term space travel
then uh we really need to find a way to
sustain ourselves uh through chronic
exposure to ionizing radiation
so what can we do to protect the body
from this particular ionizing variation
now there are there's several research
that is going on where they are trying
to focus on radiation mitigation
strategies and what i am trying to focus
on is something very unconventional
which is i'm trying to look at dinofocus
radiodurans as a model organism that can
survive very high doses of
ionizing radiation so dinofocus
radiodurance is an extremophile that can
survive twelve thousand greater than
twelve thousand degrees of radiation
which is several times larger than or
diagonalizing radiation that was created
during the
uh atomic bomb uh droppings at hiroshima
and nagasaki
the reason why this particular species
is
this
interesting is because it has several
mechanisms that help repair the dna once
it is exposed to ionizing radiation
and it has several proteins that are
involved in dna repair mechanisms that
give this particular organism an edge
when it comes to being exposed and
survival in conditions with high
ionizing radiation and it also has
certain enzymes that
give them this particular advantage to
survive
but we currently do not know all the
mechanisms that are
driving radio resistance in dinofocus
radiodurans
uh so up until now there have been some
studies that are focused on omics data
analysis uh in terms of dynafocus
radioturns
but we have still not been able to
identify a very important genes that may
be extremely crucial for the process of
radio resistance
another question that remains is even if
we do find this particular gene that may
be driving radio resistance can it be
exploited in humans
so the aim or the ration of my study is
to identify
certain conserved genes across radio
resistance species of dinofocus
and i intend to do that with rna-seq
analysis
uh even possibly identify gene
regulatory pathways via chipset analysis
which is uh
epigenetic studies where we can see how
the genetic environment of the bacteria
is modulated
uh in order to drive radio resistance
and the question that i'm trying to
solve is will we be able to identify
genes that can possibly
not just help us
in sort of like
using it for radio resistant mechanisms
or radiation mitigation and space but
can we also somehow exploit these
particular genes for cancer therapy
because
one of the largest threats in cancer
therapy is radio resistance post
radiation therapy so is there any way we
can exploit this modal organism for that
purpose
uh
so
another very uh i would say this could
be like a very ambitious thing to look
at but can we then make a synthetic
microbiome uh using these kind of
extremophiles and uh you know put them
in astronauts that would help them
survive in space in the long term
so there have been several studies uh
this far which i was i'll just explain
to you very briefly so um
scientology
posed uh dinofocus to very high amounts
of radiation and they saw certain
proteins were over expressed and they
also found certain novel small rnas that
were expressed
um
so
what they are saying is that the small
rnas would be important in looking at
downstream targets for identifying radio
resistance mechanisms
there's another study that has looked at
methylation in the dna of dinofocus
species
where they have
looked at how methylation can lead to a
regulation and down regulation of
several important genes driving daily
resistance and dinofocus
um we can actually instead of just
looking at methylation we can actually
do chip seek analysis
and very recently chipset analysis has
been done
for dinofocus species there are other
mechanisms that have also been looked at
with omics data analysis where they have
looked at this particular
pathway which is the mass ef pathway
which is another important driver of
radio resistance and dinofocus
however the treatment that was given in
this particular study was with mitomycin
and not ionizing radiation so we
currently don't know whether this could
be a good mechanism for driving radio
resistance or not
uh so this particular study
which is conducted by eugenie at all is
also looking at uh irre and ddro which
are basically transcriptional repressors
that are regulating radio resistance and
dinofocus and this is actually the first
ever chipseek study done in dinofocus
and uh has its play print is available
on bio archive so this is also very
interesting study to look at uh and this
is the tan purpose study that uh sheet
was talking about where dinofocus
species were exposed to uh the low or
earth orbit on the international space
station and then they performed omix
data analysis with the dinofocus species
to identify certain genes that may be
upregulated or downregulated in
dinofocus
well so um
not only dynamofocus radioturins but
there are different other different
types of species that are extremely uh
resistant to ionizing radiation that can
be looked at
um so what i intend to do is a
comparative transplants where i want to
identify genes that may be conserved
across species of dinofocus like
dinofocus deserty uh metalliatis
gobiances geothermalis uh the r1 species
so what i intend to do is take the
rna data of all of these particular
species and then identify conserved
genes uh because these particular
conserved genes can then be common
targets that we can actually look at
with confidence and say that they may be
important drivers of radio resistance
across the ancopa species so this is
just like uh
i'm currently working on this project so
it is work in progress so i intend to
complete the study and find something
meaningful in the field of astrobiology
and maybe someday it can be exploited
for
human purposes as well
um so
yeah i would just like to conclude my
presentation over here since i think
i've also run out of time uh but i would
say that omix data analysis as you know
uh is something that you can apply to
many many vast areas uh in biology
uh
not just uh cancer not just astrobiology
but actually any possible field that you
can think of
so that is something that i really like
about this particular area that once you
have picked up this particular skill you
can apply it to any research area of
your interest
so yeah thank you so much um
i would
love to take questions if you have any
and you can always contact me on my
email
great thank you very much urja
and subrajeet was very nice to hear your
presentations and we hope that we will
still see you soon again and
hear about the progress
um in conclusion of these great
presentations i want to share a little
bit more information
on how any one of you
can actually join the research
fellowship program
and participate in a research study
using computational tools and one of
these opportunities is a research
fellowship program run by pine biotech
so
the onyx logic research fellowship
is a program designed around
computational biology
for those that are interested not to
just learn and acquire skills but
actually develop a research study
and the research fellowship program is
designed to provide support and guidance
and what i want to do in today's brief
description of this program is explain
how does it actually work and how you
can get started
so as you heard today
many collaborators from today's speakers
were here to offer
their perspective on bioinformatics
different areas of biology and our close
collaboration with these organizations
allows us to apply
kind of a case study design to this
program so i'm really excited about uh
kind of working with a lot of the
experts in the field and being able to
make this an opportunity that anybody
can access so what in in this section
what i want to do is briefly describe
what is the research fellowship program
how to join us this fall uh how to
submit a project on the omixlogic portal
and what makes a project stand out so
first of all where are we in terms of
our program so we are working primarily
in the u.s but we do have a lot of
collaborations outside including india
and africa as you have heard in the
beginning of today's program and overall
we've had a sizable experience working
with over 15 000 participants across 162
countries so we really are agnostic
about where you live and obviously that
is because we are online and so you can
join this program virtually the program
really consists of tools for big data
analysis so we heard today
jio was mentioning how they decided to
work on viruses instead of let's say
human data
that is a typical challenge many studies
after they exceed a few samples and
large genomes you don't have tools you
run out of space you run out of ram and
so we provide that infrastructure to run
your analysis on scale
the second component that we provide is
mentorship it's really more than just
having somebody to ask a question it's
somebody that can understand what you're
trying to do and guide you with not as a
teacher right not as somebody that
actually trains you but as a mentor
somebody that can oversee make
suggestions point you in the right
direction and finally we provide
training because many people see a gap
between where they are
and the skills they need to be able to
meaningfully analyze data we provide
organized schedule training for you to
go through independently asynchronously
on your own time learn about different
types of omics data learn about
different approaches apply different
types of algorithms and therefore kind
of develop your skills and so briefly
let me first talk about some of these
resources that we provide as a part of
this program and as a part of some of
the other programs that we do as well
so one of these resources is the server
t-bioinfo platform
and the comics logic portal so you
probably all have already seen on the
symposium page right on top you have a
menu
on that menu if you click on the logo
you will go to the main omixlogic portal
just by registering there for free you
will have access to a lot of free
resources that you can try out and
explore some of the other materials that
we have after 24 hours of being on that
portal you will also get demo access to
the t by info platform and as you've
seen today there are many exciting new
features that are kind of coming out on
this platform and we also will be
showcasing them once they are ready but
already many areas of our mix data are
available for analysis on that platform
now the portal includes a personal
profile and as somebody who wants to do
research this is the place to start
anybody who is entering this field in
bioinformatics has to build up their
profile and they have to do it by
showcasing what have you achieved so if
you ask any scientist what does that
result in publications poster
presentations etc we've modeled our
profile around the same idea allowing
you to see how much you have learned
what are the courses and the programs
you're involved in and build out your
profile with relevant project
presentations now if you don't know
anything at all about a particular
interest area that you have and would
like to learn we provide
scheduled programs guided by mentors
where you can learn
synchronously by joining live sessions
and also utilize online resources so we
have a lot of asynchronous courses
starting from the very beginning and
ultimately leading you to complete
sessions with practice and so after
completing a number of those you can
interact with the mentors and you can
actually complete those areas of
specialization and earn points and so
that's another metric that we use to
communicate with the students and with
the mentors that we have because
ultimately we have a process in mind we
want everyone who wants to be
mentored who wants to do independent
research to be ready for that right not
to come with nothing to offer but come
with some basic skills that you can
showcase and so you can do that by
building up your profile and showing
what courses you have completed now we
also provide
a number of other opportunities that i
want to talk about after this but before
i do i want to ask all of you that had
the patience to stay up until now
to actually uh join us
and our mentors on our social media
platforms
so we have a group on linkedin where you
will find all of our mentors and all the
different connections that you've seen
today we try to invite all of them to
join there if you want to find their
information how to contact them you will
find them in this group so please join
on linkedin and on facebook we have two
places where we have sizable groups of
relevant contacts if you want to get
involved in these kinds of opportunities
so please join those
so as i mentioned uh you know this is
the place where you can build your
profile on learn and then connect with
mentors and through our program we'll
facilitate introductions and make
meaningful introductions with mentors if
you would like to join
um yes you're welcome to join the groups
the group on linkedin
so
what is the training part of what we do
first of all we have some basic
coursework that you can learn about
bioinformatics and what it includes
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and data science how to work
with data how to code an r in python how
to run big data analysis pipelines how
to do data wrangling and visualization
right so all of those things are covered
in that portion as well
then we have specialized training
including next generation sequencing
rna-seq analysis or single cell analysis
and a lot of similar courses that you
can either take asynchronously or guided
by a person
finally we provide introductory projects
that you can take to understand a
particular domain like the source code
ii i saw a lot of questions today about
what will be the impact of a mutation or
how will the mutation affect
transmission or things like that so we
cover a lot of those questions using
publicly available data and publications
to try to answer those based on the data
that is available
now as i mentioned a lot of that is not
possible on your own laptop and so
that's why as a part of this program you
and as a part of just registering
actually on the portal you get access to
our big data analysis platform so there
you have access to various processing
tools statistical analysis tools
different types of machine learning
models as well as more advanced kind of
sections for multinomics integration and
biological interpretation
now after this you're ready for the
fellowship after the basic training what
is essentially the fellowship itself
the fellowship is how to go beyond that
and that's where you get an opportunity
to spend three months or six months to
work on an independent project that you
design that you essentially come up with
a topic you then find the data set
perform literature review and work with
the mentor to complete it what does it
mean to complete it
completing it means that you present
that to your peers
and experts for feedback so as you know
we kind of rely on signs published in
peer-reviewed journals well peer review
is an important part that essentially
combines working with others and then
submitting your findings for credit
critique
questions and and feedback and so that's
essentially the outcome of this program
now many people struggle with the first
part of that path and the first part
part is finding a topic for your project
or choosing a topic for a project and so
what we recommend is kind of thinking
about it as the intersection of three
different areas a topic that you know
and care about
something that will be interesting to an
audience and something that has
available data you can actually find
data sets that describe that and provide
you with data
so after you do that you might want to
go through some examples and we provide
a number of different practical examples
that you can go through such as
epigenetics of asthma modeling precision
treatment of breast cancer
deep
sourcing sequencing of poliovirus as we
heard today from raoul
different types of ecological projects
analysis of the changing immune
responses in cancer for immunotherapy
microbiome biomarkers from the american
gut microbiome project whole
transcriptome profiling of cancer tumors
and mouse pdx models deregulation of
subcellular networks in cancer patients
using the cancer genome atlas different
types of biotechnology
agriculture
neuroscience virology and finally your
own project so after surveying some of
the projects and kind of understanding
how they were organized now you are
ready to start working on your own
project
but just choosing a topic like oncology
or virology or even extremophiles is not
enough
as you have seen in today's
presentations what makes a project stand
out
part of it is
what are you focusing on and so an
important part of what you can focus on
it comes from literature comes from the
body body of research work conducted by
others where you can review available
publications and you can understand what
they cover and where are those gaps and
unanswered questions or controversy or
debates where there's disagreement and
gaps in current research and that can
help you make your hypothesis more
specific and essentially define
your unique question
then we have some resources that we can
help you with to try and find data sets
to try and address that gap or
controversy with a data set and so as
you know there's millions of data sets
out there that you can survey and
identify something that might lead you
in the right direction
obviously that's not easy and so that's
why
we have a slack channel that we invited
all of you to join where you can start
interacting with mentors
following a weekly regular progress
report
and essentially have somebody to give
you feedback as you develop the project
and as you start working on the analysis
now again all of that
is following a process that already is
implemented on the learn portal
once your profile reaches 10 000 points
and you complete your profile
then you have to complete a course on
how to design and complete a
bioinformatics project and then you will
be able to add a project of your own
okay and so
what are some of the elements of this
program number one
you do a comprehension and analysis of
existing types of data existing types of
literature
and essentially questions that are being
asked in the domain that you find
interesting
you then learn how to investigate not
based on ideas and just hypotheses that
others have proposed but think
critically about the data that you find
and learn how to test your hypotheses
explore the data and find meaningful
patterns
and another component is not just doing
the analysis but also being able to
describe it and so that's the final part
where you learn to organize your
thoughts and ideas into something that
is ready to be shown and reviewed by an
expert in the field
and so we've defined this as a specific
step-by-step process that we go through
in weekly meetings and ultimately help
you organize all of that information
into something that you can put together
assembling a poster presentation or
perhaps a preprint or even a publication
submitted to a journal and so as you
have seen today many of the people that
spoke are past research fellows like
orja and you've heard and she also went
through the same process developing her
project submitting a poster presentation
getting feedback and working through
that feedback and ultimately planning to
publish some of her research
in tomorrow's session you will also hear
about some of the other programs that
we've conducted where multiple students
work together on poster presentations
either together with our team or
independently what does that allow you
to do first of all it allows you to
really practice the skills that you have
learned and try to conduct independent
research but also as you will hear from
urja and many others that you will meet
tomorrow you will see how this helps you
stand out and essentially kind of get
your attention in the field that you
want to be in whether it's
bioinformatics or a particular area of
research in a certain community
and so ultimately many of the people
that we have worked with have went on to
present receive prizes get recognition
and including recognition on our own
portal in situations like these where we
bring together others who are interested
in this field experts students and
others to really provide good feedback
and help them kind of understand what
they can do more with the type of
information the type of research that
they have done now this applies to many
different types of students including
high school students undergraduate
students as well as graduate students
and we've worked with many graduate
students phd and post-docs essentially
helping them transition from learning
bioinformatics to them being able to
apply bioinformatics in a meaningful way
to kind of work through their research
ideas and get meaningful insights maybe
before they generate the data or maybe
knowing what to do with the data they
generate
and also we have worked with a number of
students in high schools in the us
in a lot of the programs that you will
hear about tomorrow students have
reached out to us and have utilized the
resources that we compiled to help them
work through a research project
and some of them even completed a full
phd proposal just working on this kind
of a research fellowship
so
as we conclude i just briefly want to
answer a few common questions that
students have when they hear about this
opportunity
so can this program be
used for the requirement of a university
internship the answer is yes
what is the difference between three and
six months programs the difference is
that if you just want to apply
bioinformatics skills to your project
you only need three months if you want
to
learn about bioinformatics and then do
this you might need a longer time
if you want to complete a full research
study you definitely need at least six
months
how many hours commitment does the
research fellowship require so the
answer to that varies and the answer
varies because some people come from
more of a computational background some
come from more of a biology background
after i'm done you will see some of the
posters that people submitted for the
poster competition
many of them came knowing nothing about
bioinformatics but it took them a longer
time to get up to speed
some of them came with advanced
knowledge of bioinformatics but they
learned new methods and applied them to
an interesting data set
what are the mentorship options so we do
provide several types of mentorship
through the program
one option is just meeting in those
regular meetings with a trainer and a
mentor that can provide you with some
general guidelines
another opportunity is to work with a
mentor one-on-one on a project of your
own where a mentor essentially helps you
figure out what to do
and the final option is the other way
around is to join a project that is
organized by somebody else
which means that an expert says i want
to study this question and i would like
you to help so those are the three
options that are available
can you choose any topic for your
analysis the answer is yes
can you participate in group projects
again the answer is yes we have many
examples for those that work together
with their faculty for example or with
the whole class
and then finally pricing payment options
and scholarships so let me just briefly
show you where you can find all of that
information
so if you're already signed up on the
learnomicslogic.com portal
you can quickly go and explore the
courses that i talked about but right
here under programs
you will find some
programs that we offer and if you search
here if you don't find it right here you
can search right here
and you will see research fellowship
and under the research fellowship you
will find all of the information that
you need including our upcoming dates
that we will post by tomorrow for when
this will start because the current
batch is ending on august 30th
so i welcome all of you to explore this
and kind of understand how it works if
you have any questions feel free to
reach out to us at marketing
pine dot bio